[موسيقى]
بجانب الاخر ان الشعر العام من ناحيه
المؤرخين اغلبهم لا يعرف لا يصبر اغوار
القصيده وانما يكتفي اذا كان اشاره هناك
ان هذه القصيده قيلت في هذا يكتفي بعرضها
فقط اما درستها وتحقيقها واستخراج
دلالاتها فلم يتطرق لها
[موسيقى]
موسوعه الملك عبد العزيز في الشعر الشعبي
كم مجلد هذا يا استاذ سعد
تم تسليمه سبع مجلدات سبع مجلدات يعني
الشعر يعني كل ما قيل عن الملك عبد العزيز
هذا مشروع قامت فيه اداره الملك عبد
العزيز قسم قسم الشعر العام فلما قدم
المشروع كان ااا مولاي خادم الحرمين
الشريفين ايام كان امير الرياض عن الشعر
موسوعه الملك عبد العزيز في الشعر العربي
قال اضيفه لها الشعر الشعبي لانه هو
القريب من الاحداث والمهم
الملك سلمان وهو صاحب البصر او البصيره
التاريخيه في قيمه الشعر الشعبي
[موسيقى]